-You are here.
It is a great day
to be in New York City.
Well, unless you're one person.
[ Laughter ]
Today, history was made today
in New York City
as former president Trump
became the first U.S. president
to ever be arrested
and face criminal charges.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When they heard,
New Yorkers were like,
-♪ It's about damn time ♪
-Yeah. Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Trump made history.
The only good news for Trump,
in Florida,
all the history books
have been thrown out.
So it's all right.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, on his way to court,
Trump posted on social media
from the car.
He wrote,
"Heading to Lower Manhattan,
the courthouse.
Seems so surreal.
Wow, they are
going to arrest me.
Can't believe this
is happening in America.
MAGA!"
[ Laughter ]
When Trump sits in the back
of a car,
he's like a little kid.
You've got to give him
a bag of Cheerios and an iPad.
It's like, "We'll be
at court soon, honey."
[ Laughter ]
Trump eventually
reached the courthouse.
Here he is walking in.
-...outside his vehicle,
once they have a handle
of the security here.
And then you see
the former president...
-Gave a little wave there.
[ Laughter ]
Gave a little wa--
Can we -- who is --
Can we see who he's waving at?
-...once they have a handle
of the security here.
And then you see
the former president...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow.
[ Applause ]
That is biz-- That is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The odds --
The odds of that happening.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Well, once he was inside,
Trump was booked
and fingerprinted.
If you want to know
what his fingerprints look like,
just look at
a "Don't walk" sign.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump was actually
fingerprinted.
They didn't even use an ink pad.
They just used the McRib sauce
that was already on his fingers.
[ Laughter ]
Once he got inside
the courtroom,
Trump was formally charged
with 34 counts
of falsifying business records
in the first degree,
which are class E felonies.
Yep, Trump was like, "Of course,
they were very classy felonies."
[ Laughter ]
"Some would say
the classiest of felonies."
[ Laughter ]
If this goes to trial,
prosecutors plan to call
Stormy Daniels as a witness.
-Stormy Daniels!
-Stormy Daniels -- Yeah.
Stormy Daniels heard
and was like,
"Haven't I witnessed enough?"
[ Laughter ]
Here's a picture of Trump
inside the courtroom.
Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like he's watching
another table at Applebee's
get their food first.
[ Laughter ]
Could we see him again?
That face?
Yeah. He looks...
[ Laughter ]
Looks like he had to sit through
two unskippable ads on YouTube.
[ Laughter ]
Let me just see it
one more time.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like Ben Affleck
at the Grammys.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Rimshot ]
Meanwhile, earlier today,
Marjorie Taylor Greene
and George Santos
both showed up
outside the courthouse,
and it was absolute chaos.
It was basically the craziest
Thanksgiving Day Parade.
[ Laughter ]
Even Times Square Elmo was like,
"If they try to engage,
just walk right past them.
Don't even --
Don't engage with the --"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
But as soon as George Santos
showed up outside
the courthouse,
he was swarmed by reporters.
Take a look at this photo.
Yeah. Trump saw the media
following Santos, was like,
"Hey, get your own arraignment!"
[ Laughter ]
Marjorie Taylor Greene
was then interviewed
about Trump's indictment,
and she made
an interesting comparison.
Listen to this.
-I mean, think about --
Gosh, think about this.
President Trump is joining some
of the most incredible people
in history,
being arrested today.
Nelson Mandela was arrested,
served time in prison.
Jesus.
Jesus was arrested.
[ Laughter ]
-Jesus -- Jesus saw that
and said, "Jesus..."
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it was a long day
of media coverage,
with reporters starting
early in the morning
and talking nonstop
about the case.
I admire their dedication,
but I think some of them
need to take a break.
Check out this clip
I saw earlier today on CNN.
-[ Hoarsely ] After the search
warrant at Mar-a-Lago,
he raised a million dollars.
After being indicted,
he raised $7 million.
-[ Hoarsely ] We do know that
there's a videographer
along with him right now.
-[ Hoarsely ] It's not that
out of the ordinary
to ask for a change in venue.
Staten Island, I think,
went majority for Trump,
so no wonder he's trying
to get over there again.
-[ Laughs hoarsely ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get a little water,
something.
[ Applause ]
Need a little water.
Oh, and I saw that
Senator Lindsey Graham
said Trump's indictment
almost ensures
that he will be
the 2024 Republican nominee.
But now several other members
of Congress
are speaking out
about the situation.
For example,
Senator Mark Kelly said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Congressman
Jack Bergman said...
[ Laughter ]
And Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Congressman Raul Ruiz
said...
Then Senator Tom Cotton said...
[ Laughter ]
Congressman Brad Sherman said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Congressman George Santos
said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Congresswoman
Chellie Pingree said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Congressman Richard Neal
said...
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Senator Mark Kelly said...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]